FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Welcome, fellow
Googlers, and guests.
I'm very excited
today to introduce
an incredibly inspiring
person, author, and speaker,
Joe Plumeri, who is
here today to share
a bit about his new book, "The
Power of Being Yourself-- A
Game Plan for Success
by Putting Passion
into Your Work and Life."
Joe Plumeri is the former CEO
of Willis Group, and Citibank
North America.
He now serves as the Vice
Chairman of First Data
Corporation, and a member
of its board of directors.
His passion, honesty,
and sense of purpose
flows through the pages of his
book, as well as his speeches.
So please join me in
welcoming Joe Plumeri.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE PLUMERI: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all for coming.
I appreciate it very much.
First of all, I should tell
you why I wrote this book.
I am not a writer.
I don't do that for a living.
But I have passion, and I have
a point of view about things.
And a couple years
ago, I started
to think about-- as you all
do-- about life in general,
and how things are going.
And I said to myself, you
know, it's interesting
how we all celebrate
authenticity in this country.
We think authenticity is great.
We see people who
are genuine, and we
say that person is
really a real person.
And then we see
everything's filtered today
through emails, texts,
Instagrams, Twitters,
LinkedIns, and by the time you
get through all of that stuff,
you wonder what's
true, and what's false.
I see in companies,
people send emails
because they don't want to
be there when people are
reading it on the other end.
And I think about how unfamiliar
we've become with each other.
I watch television, and
I see people read off
of teleprompters.
And I ask myself, did
they really write that?
Do they really feel that
way about the subject,
or does somebody
else feel that way?
I see people on television get
choked up, and begin to cry.
And they apologize
immediately for crying.
And I ask myself, why
are they apologizing
for being themselves, and being
genuine about who they are?
And I think about our
society, and are we
being disconnected with how
we really feel about things?
And so I wanted to
write this book.
I had in my head to do it
for all of those reasons.
And then a couple years ago,
my son-- my now-oldest son
was running in the
Boston Marathon.
And it was the day of the
terrorist attack in Boston.
And you'll read
about it in the book.
And it's really
what motivated me
to write the book, when I saw
people's emotions that day.
I saw them caring
for each other.
I saw people helping each other.
I saw people terrorized.
And I said, why do we have
to wait for an occasion?
Why do we have to wait
for a wedding, a funeral,
or a catastrophe for people
to really show who they are?
Why can't we be
that way every day?
So what I did was to set
about stories in the book
about being yourself,
either my stories,
or other people's stories.
And I didn't do it by
virtue of chapters.
I did it by virtue
of principles, things
that I believed in.
So that when you
read the book, it's
not something you put
back on the shelf and say,
OK, I read that book.
But it's something that
you could use every day.
And something that you could
remind yourself all about.
And I tried to be-- and I
know I was-- as transparent
as you possibly could be.
Because otherwise, the book
would not have integrity.
I'm just going to talk to you
about a few of the principles.
One of the principles is, we
all got the same plumbing.
Now you're asking me,
what is that all about?
What that's about
is, is I've traveled
throughout the whole world.
And what I found out was, is
that whether you're from Asia,
or whether you're
from Indianapolis,
from South America,
or wherever you're
from, everybody
feels the same feeling
that we all do.
And that if we
understood that better,
maybe the world would be a
little bit nicer, and more
peaceful.
Because I have
traveled the world.
I was the CEO of a British
company for 13 years.
And you would think
when everybody
talks about the British
and being stiff, and stiff
upper lip, and they
don't laugh a lot,
they don't do all
that kind of stuff.
I found the direct
opposite of all of that.
But you hear that, and you begin
to think that people really
don't understand what
other people are all about.
When I got to this company-- it
was called the Willis Group--
it didn't make very much money.
Didn't make any money at all.
So I had to do something
to get everybody
engaged in the company.
And so what I did was--
and I didn't know this--
but I created these
little pins that everybody
could wear with Willis on it.
And I thought that if
everybody wore a pin
they'd become sort of
like part of the company.
And everybody would
start to feel a sense
of being a part of things.
And I didn't know the British
don't like wearing pins.
Nobody told me that.
As a matter of fact, they're
really disgusted with the pin.
But they knew that
when I showed up,
if they didn't wear
the pin, that I
would give them a hard time.
Which I never did.
I just stared at their lapels
to see if they had a pin on.
So when people would
walk down the hall,
I always knew that they
didn't have a pin on,
because a woman would
go in the men's room,
and a man would go
in the women's room
so they wouldn't confront me.
And so one day-- and I knew that
this happened in the company--
they felt that when
they confronted me
they'd have to know
what was going on.
They'd have to have a reason
to not have their pin on.
So I get the one guy,
and I look at his lapel,
I don't say anything to him.
And he says, "Oh,
Mr. Chairman, I'm
sorry I don't have my pin on.
I left it on my pajamas."
When you think
about that, and you
think about that
kind of humor, you
wouldn't think that
would come from what
your perception is of a Brit.
We dedicated a building in
London a few years later.
Made the company successful.
Became a global company.
And I built a building
in London right
across from Lloyd's of London.
So I have to dedicate the
building, and they say to me,
"Who are you going to have
to dedicate the building?"
I said, "Me.
I'm going to dedicate."
But apparently in London,
you don't dedicate buildings
unless you have royalty
in these buildings.
So a friend of mine says,
I can get you some royalty.
I said, who could you get?
He picks up the phone, and
he talks to Prince Andrew.
Now, I come from a neighborhood
in Trenton, New Jersey.
I don't know royalty from Adam.
But he gets the prince to
show up for the dedication.
Now in advance of
the dedication,
I get a long list of
things that you're not
supposed to do when
you're around royalty.
One of them is, you
don't touch royalty.
You just put your hands,
and you don't touch them.
So I said, this makes me
nervous, because I'm a toucher.
Like I did with all of you, I
said hello when you came in.
It's just the way I am.
So I meet him
outside the building.
And interestingly
enough, he drives up
with his own Range Rover.
There's no entourage.
He just drives up by himself.
He gets out of the car.
So I feel more
comfortable with him.
And it's going to be
like three or four
hours before the two of
us dedicate the building.
So I take him
around and so forth.
And I said to him,
I gotta tell you.
I'm a little bit nervous.
He said, what are
you nervous about?
I said, I'm nervous
because there's
this long list that says I'm
not supposed to touch you.
So I want you to
know in advance,
before I'm arrested,
that I might touch you.
I'm sorry, I don't mean it.
So we dedicate the building.
And during the ceremony,
I give a speech.
And during the
speech, I read a note
from my mother, who
was alive at the time.
And the note said
something to the effect,
thank you to Prince Andrew
for being nice to my son
Joey-- my mother's from Italy.
And she appreciates
it very much.
And he's very honored,
and he's very nervous.
So please take care of him.
Something along those lines.
So I read the note,
everybody applauds.
I get a standing ovation.
And as I turn around,
the prince is there,
and he gives me a hug.
And everybody's astounded that
the prince is giving me a hug.
And I said to myself,
again, isn't it interesting
when you have a perception
that people don't
do those kinds of things,
that really we're more alike
than anything else.
I've never gone around
the world, any place--
because I'm pretty enthusiastic,
as you see-- where I've
said to somebody,
nice job, good job,
and they've said to
me, stop telling me
I've done a nice job.
I'm tired of hearing that.
Or they said to me,
you're too enthusiastic.
Don't be so enthusiastic.
We all got the same plumbing.
I've never heard anybody,
any place in the world,
tell me otherwise.
So if you understand that as
you're dealing with the world--
the message in that
principle is that you're
dealing with the world.
We may look different.
We may talk different.
But at the end of the day,
we've all got the same plumbing.
We all got the same insides.
We all got the same heart.
And it's really
important that we
begin to get in
touch with our heart,
even here, where it's the
center of information.
Here at Google, there's
one thing you can't do.
I google all day long.
I got a piece of information I
want, I take my cell phone out,
and I google it.
But one thing that you can't
do, and you ought to try it,
is try googling your heart.
Or try googling my heart.
And you'll get the
lyrics of a song.
You'll get the way
the heart is shaped.
And what I'm talking
about is your feelings,
and how you express
yourself, and how
you relate to each other.
Which is really,
I think, important
in a society today
that is lacking that.
And is lacking the risk-taking,
and everything else
that you need to do.
So that is the first principle.
And it's really
interesting stories.
And there are other stories
about people who have
the same plumbing in the book.
Another principle I talk about,
which is really interesting,
is make your heart
your teleprompter.
Now you'll ask me,
what's that about?
I go to speak at the
Georgia Dome one year.
And usually when
you go speak, they
want you to test the
microphone, or to test whatever.
And the guy said, let's
work on the teleprompter.
And I said, I don't
use the teleprompter.
He said, well, what do you use?
I said, I brought
my own teleprompter.
He said, nobody brings
their own teleprompter.
What are you talking about?
I said, I brought my own.
He said, where is it?
I said, my teleprompter
is right here.
It's my heart.
I speak from my heart.
I don't read from a speech.
I don't read from notes.
I speak from my heart.
And what I mean by
that in that principle
is that today nobody
takes any risks.
Nobody goes out
and does anything
unless a poll was taken.
Nobody does anything
unless a survey is taken.
unless there's a consensus.
And then it's OK,
and it's safe to do.
Instead of going out
and actually doing
what's in your heart
that you think is right.
And I tell a couple of stories
in the book about that.
One of the stories
I tell is in 2000,
when I became chairman
and CEO of Willis.
The first thing you do when
you become a CEO is you
look at all the things that
happened in the company.
And the company
wasn't doing well.
So I wanted to see
everything that was going on.
So I looked at the
benefits policy.
And the benefits
policy did not include
benefits for domestic partners.
And I thought, that's not right.
I think benefits should be
given to domestic partners.
I think everybody should
be treated equally.
Now if you go back to 2000,
that wasn't fashionable.
Nobody made me do it.
There was no polls
and surveys, or rants
and raves about everybody being
given equal rights domestically
in benefits in companies.
I just thought it was
the right thing to do.
So I changed it without
anybody asking me to do it.
Because in my heart, I thought
it was the right thing to do.
In the company is a guy
by name of Bryan Eure,
who is a broker at Willis.
And eventually he gets
married to Bill White,
and they have a big wedding
at the Four Seasons restaurant
in New York City.
I had no idea why this guy was
at Willis until that night.
And he gets up to give
the speech at his wedding.
There's 700 people there.
And he gets up to give
his speech, and he says,
I want to thank Joe
Plumeri, because without Joe
Plumeri being at Willis, I
would never be here tonight,
or marrying Bill White.
It was right after New
York changed the law
to be able to be married.
And he went on to say,
when he was looking
for a job in New York City, he
found that the only insurance
broker in New York
that he could find
that gave benefits to domestic
partners was the Willis Group.
And I want to thank Joe Plumeri
for changing that benefit.
Or I wouldn't be here tonight.
Up until that night, I had no
idea why the guy was at Willis.
And he announced that
in front of 700 people.
That just moved me so much.
Because I said to myself, if
I hadn't done what I thought
was right, he wouldn't be here.
He wouldn't be getting married,
wouldn't be in New York City.
And I wonder how many
people are holding back
from doing what is right
and in their heart,
and being themselves, rather
than waiting for a survey,
or conventional wisdom
to tell them what to do.
You'll see in the book,
there's a forward from a man
by the name of Joe Califano, who
none of you have ever heard of.
But you notice these days that
not many people smoke much
anymore.
If I ever told you
that people wouldn't
smoke in pubs in Ireland,
or places like that,
you'd be amazed.
Because that's what they do.
They were born doing that.
Well, who's Joe Califano?
He was the domestic adviser
for Lyndon Johnson in the '60s.
And you might have read about
the Great Society, which
is where Medicare and
Medicaid come from.
So if you want to know where
Medicaid and Medicare came
from, it was the
Great Society that
was written by Joe Califano
under Lyndon Johnson.
He was the Secretary of
Health, Education, and Welfare
under Jimmy Carter.
In 1978, he declared
that smoking
be prohibited in federal
buildings, and in airplanes.
And there were such
an outcry that he
was fired by Jimmy
Carter, because
of banning smoking in
1978 in federal buildings,
and airplanes.
And after he was fired,
he dedicated himself.
Because the headline said
that Joe Califano called
smoking slow-motion suicide.
So if you're wondering where
the nonsmoking thing started.
When if you see
television series
that go back to the '50s and
'60s, and everybody smokes.
If you're asking yourself,
where did it start?
Who started this whole thing
with no smoking in buildings,
and here, and you can't do
that, and you can't do this.
It was Joe Califano.
All because in his
heart, even though he
knew he would be
fired, he thought
it was the right thing to do.
How many people today, knowing
that they're going to be fired,
do that?
People don't do that today.
They do what's
politically correct today.
They know that I got to do
what my boss tells me to do,
even though it's not
the right thing to do,
or what society tells me to do.
But that's where the whole
nonsmoking thing started.
So to me, he didn't
need a teleprompter
to tell him what to say.
His heart told him
what to say, even
though he knew he
would be fired.
And the forward of this
book is written by him.
And I am proud that
that's the case.
There's another
principle in the book
called, let sadness teach you.
Which is one that I share
and want to share with you.
It's about my
relationship with my son
Chris, who passed away six years
ago because of drug addiction.
At 13 years old,
he was anorexic,
as it turned out because
of a self-esteem problem.
My relationship with
him from the period
of 13 years old until when
he died at the age of 40,
was obviously
contentious, and one
where I tried very hard
to rebuild my relationship
with him that hadn't been built
before he was 13 years old.
And I tell as transparently,
and as truthfully,
and in a raw way, what
my relationship with him
was all about.
I did all of the conventional
things that you should do.
Send him to hospitals,
send him to therapists,
send him to every place
that you can send people
to go to be rehabilitated.
But we never regained the
kind of a relationship
that we should have.
Because I think as I was
starting my meteoric rise,
if you will, to the top
of the corporate world,
I wasn't the parent
that I should have been.
The reality was, is that
I neglected my own son,
even though I did the
cosmetic things that you're
supposed to do to get him help.
Maybe, I say to myself, I should
have taken a year off of work
rather than worry about
the next board meeting.
And I tell that story.
Interestingly
enough, I remember,
the company I was running was
owned by American Express.
And he was arrested
for credit card fraud
and went to jail for 18 months.
And I went to visit
him every weekend.
But I could never seem
to repair the damage that
had been done because of the
neglect that had happened.
I tell that story.
And I tell that story
not only to parents,
and I tell that story not
only to children of parents--
it goes both ways.
Is that I think one of the
most important things in life
are the relationships
that you have.
Don't neglect them.
If you're a parent, the most
important thing you have to do
is to make sure that you're
close to your children.
When you see them, hug them,
tell them that you love them.
If you're a child, and
you're listening to me now,
and you're talking to
your parent, hug them,
tell them that you love them.
Because at the end of the day,
the last thing you want to do
is feel the regret of not
having that relationship.
I talk about the
pain of discipline,
and the pain of regret.
When you think about
life, it really
gets down to those two
things, doesn't it?
You either have the
pain of discipline,
which is the short-term
pain that you have
because you've got
to do something.
But when you think about it,
it doesn't last very long.
It's just short-term pain.
But the pain of regret, when
you've ever felt regret,
lasts longer, and it
just never goes away.
And it's those kinds
of things in life
that I think are important.
And I think about my son.
And I think about the regret
that I had with regard to that.
And it's something
that never goes away.
And I think about it over,
and over, and over again.
And the same thing relates
to friendships that you have.
If there's somebody
that you haven't
talked to in a long time.
Or somebody that
you're meaning to call.
Where you're running
something, yeah, I've
been meaning to call you.
I got to tell you, do it.
Before it's too late
to do it, and you
regret not having done it.
By the way, that same reason,
this whole idea of neglect
not only applies to children,
and parents, friends,
but also applies to clients.
For people that are listening
to me with regard to business,
the number one reason you
lose a client is neglect.
You could make all the mistakes
in the world that you want,
but the one mistake you
can't make is neglect them.
Because they'll go someplace
else where they feel
there's love.
It's a wonderful
principle for you to read.
And when I say, let
sadness teach you,
I tell it so other people don't
go through the same thing I do.
And the last principle I'll
talk to you about is called,
look up, not down.
We're all going to
have adversity in life.
I was running Willis in 2008.
For those of you who remember,
the world fell apart in 2008.
We had the Great Recession.
The banks were closed.
No credit.
Couldn't buy anything.
Terrible time to
be around, frankly.
So in 2008, I made the
decision to buy a company
for $2 billion, which
is a lot of money
not only in 2008
but at any time.
It's supposed to close
in October of that year.
The problem is, between June and
October, the world fell apart.
So all the financing that
I was supposed to get,
I got, but only for a
short period of time.
Instead of it being permanent,
it was temporary financing.
That's in October,
and the deal closes.
In November, my son passes away.
So between October
and November, I
don't know what worse
could happen to me.
It's the time when I
could-- two choices.
I could go dig a
hole and jump in it.
Or I could get up in the morning
and go attack my problems,
which I think you should do.
You should always
attack your fears,
because your fears
are your limitations.
If you don't
overcome your fears,
you're going to be limited
by them all your life.
And so I had to go attack them.
I talk about that.
It turns out that after
I made this acquisition,
this other company,
Hilb Rogal & Hobbs,
had five offices in Chicago.
And what I needed to do was to
merge the five offices they had
and the two offices
that I have so that they
could be more efficient.
We can grow one
culture rather than
have all these offices
spend more money,
and not have the same culture.
So I looked to see
in Chicago where
there was a lot of
buildings with that room,
with that space.
And the one place where
they had a lot of space
was the famous Sears
Tower in Chicago.
You all heard of the
Sears Tower in Chicago?
Which is no longer called
the Sears Tower in Chicago,
and I'll tell you that story.
Tallest building in
the Western Hemisphere.
Nothing like it.
The problem was, is that it
was less than 70% occupied.
And the reason was is when
the tenants' leases came up,
they were all afraid that the
next terrorist attack was going
to be the Sears Tower, because
it was the largest building
in the Western Hemisphere.
So as soon as the lease came
up, they got out of there.
So there was a lot
of empty space.
So I thought I had
a great opportunity
to negotiate with the
owner a good deal.
Because he had a
lot of empty space.
The banks were
not lending money.
The credit markets were closed.
What a great opportunity,
that I could turn adversity
into something that's really
terrific and positive.
So I meet with the
owner, and I say to him,
I need 250,000 square feet--
which is, by the way, about 3%
of the building.
And he says, I have
a lot of space.
I could do a good deal for you.
I knew I could.
And he says to me, so what
would you like to pay?
I said, well, what's the
average rent in the building?
He says, $35 a square foot.
So I said, I don't want
to tell you what I pay.
I don't want to insult you.
He said, tell me what you want.
It's OK.
Tell me.
I said, no I don't
want to insult you.
He said, no, tell
me what you want.
I said, $10.
He says, you insult me.
So I got up to go away.
And he said, no, he
says, let's do something.
I'm making a long story that's
a wonderful story in the book.
We arrive at $14.50
a square foot.
Now for anybody who's in
the real estate business,
or even renting, you know that
$14.50 a square foot is like
nothing.
I mean, I don't know what
it is a square foot here.
This is like hallowed
ground, where I am now.
I mean, you're talking-- I'm
serious-- 100s of dollars
a square foot.
This is $14.50 a square foot
in the middle of Chicago,
the largest building in
the Western Hemisphere,
$14.50 a square foot.
He says to me, do
we have a deal now?
I said, not exactly.
He says, what do you want now?
I said, you know what the
problem with this building is?
It's a jinx.
I says, it's a jinx,
because the Sears name
connotes that a
terrorist attack is going
to-- you need a positive name.
He says, what name
should I put up there?
I said, Willis.
Nobody knew who Willis was.
They thought it was that
little kid on television.
You know, what's up, Willis?
And he says, Willis?
Nobody knows Willis.
So I said, you put
Willis up there,
I said, you'll get a new
positive name rather than
the old Sears name
on the building.
So he says, I got
to think about it.
I don't know if I could do that.
Comes back the next day,
he says, I could do it.
He says, but I gotta tell
you, I gotta charge you.
Now we've been
negotiating now for days.
He said blue, I said black.
He said white, I said green.
We never agreed on anything
until he says that.
And I say to him, OK.
He's startled that
I agree with him.
He says, you'll do it?
I said, absolutely.
He says, do we have a deal?
I said, not exactly.
He said, what do you want now?
I said, I'll give
you a million dollars
if you give me a million
dollars worth of business.
Because we're not
your client, and you
need to insure the building.
So you give me a
million dollars,
I'll give you a million dollars.
I says, you do that?
He says, if I do that,
do we have a deal?
I said, not exactly.
He said, why not?
I said, your partners
who are not my clients,
you've got to get them
to give me the business.
So we finally
decide on the deal.
And we rename the
building the Willis Tower,
which is what it is
today in Chicago.
I only took 3% of the building.
I don't own it.
I didn't own it.
I used to wear my pin, and
people would say to me,
are you the guy that
bought the Sears Tower?
And I said to myself, I got a
long story and a short story.
The long story is
too much to tell.
So I said, yeah.
Sure.
I bought it.
It's interesting, the night
we dedicated the building,
Brian Williams-- the
famous Brian Williams--
says to me, how after all these
years it's been called Sears--
and by the way, Sears
hadn't been in that building
since 1993.
How is it you show up
and change the name?
I said, I asked.
Now, strange as that
sounds, see what
it's all about is, you've
got to wake up every morning
with a core belief.
Whatever you want to
believe, you believe.
I believe anything's possible.
If you believe anything's
possible, you're going to ask.
We live in a world where
the possibilities are
less, and less, and less, rather
than more, and more, and more.
And I tell you that story,
and I want you remember it,
because don't be afraid to ask.
Don't be afraid to feel
that anything is possible.
By the way, today, the
Willis Tower in Chicago
is now almost 100% occupied.
Not because the
economy came back.
But after Willis moved in
and they changed the name,
United Airlines moved 2,200
people into the building.
And then six months
to nine months later,
United Airlines and
Continental Airlines
merged to become the largest
airline in the world.
And where's their headquarters?
The Willis Tower in Chicago.
So after all that
adversity, and after all
of that upset with
the economy, my son,
you've got to be positive.
You've got to believe
anything is possible.
And you have to face
adversity, and face your fears.
And as you look at that
tower, when you see it on TV--
and you will.
Or somebody mentions
it-- and they will.
Just remember the
story, anything's
possible you gotta ask.
And so the book, and I
offer you those principles,
as just some idea
of what's in there.
Some examples of
what's in there.
Going to make you cry.
It'll make you laugh.
That's good.
That's what we're all about,
is to cry, and to laugh,
and at the end the day
feel better about life,
and feel better about yourself.
OK?
Thank you very much for
listening, everybody.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE PLUMERI: Shall I do Q&A?
Anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Joe, thanks
for the talk, very inspiring.
JOE PLUMERI: Thanks for coming.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I'd like to know how many
books you have written,
and what inspired you
to write about this book
and share with all of us?
JOE PLUMERI: As I
said in the beginning,
I've always felt that,
I think technology
is a wonderful thing.
And I'm standing in the center
of the mecca of technology.
But I think technology should
not be instead of people,
it should be on
behalf of people.
And I think that we overuse
our sense of connection
and information, and our
communication with each other.
And our society has become more
mechanical than it should be.
I don't write about it in the
book, but maybe I should've.
But when I took over Citibank,
I noticed that all people
did all day was email.
This was back in 1995.
So I shut the email system off.
And I don't know why I
didn't write about it.
I shut the email system off,
and they thought I was crazy.
Because I saw people weren't
talking to each other.
And they were
emailing each other
in the same floor, when they
could be talking to each other,
and saying, hi, how you doing?
Because again, I go
back to so many people
send things because they
don't want to be there
when somebody reads it.
And they don't want to feel
the emotion on the other side.
And I think that if
you look at history,
and you look at what's
moved this country, what's
moved the world, is people's
emotions, their courage,
their sense of invention,
their sense of creativity.
Look where I'm standing.
The creativity and the
invention that took place here,
because people had the
sense to take risks.
And I want people to sit
around the dinner table
by virtue of this book and kind
of reconnect to each other.
And that's why I
tell these stories.
And if I could start that
conversation and have people
start to communicate
a little bit more
than we do now, and start the
narrative with regard to that.
I got to tell you,
you're looking
at a guy that cries a lot.
I don't mind telling
you I cry a lot.
I've been the CEO of
a lot of companies.
And nobody ever told
me I was a weak guy.
Nobody ever told me that
I cry, so therefore they
didn't think I was tough.
I was tough.
But that doesn't mean
I can't show who I am.
And I think the more that we
do that, the closer our society
becomes, and maybe there's less
Fergusons in the world today.
So that's what inspired
me to write this book.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Is that the only book
that you have written?
JOE PLUMERI: Yes.
I'm not a writer.
I'm just an Italian
kid from New Jersey.
I'm not a writer.
I don't do that for a living.
I just had the
inspiration to want
to create the
dialogue with people
about what's in their heart.
And hopefully more
people will be inspired
to use their heart more.
I think that it's really
important in our society.
AUDIENCE: So you've talked a lot
about how you used your heart
as your teleprompter.
And I was wondering
if you could comment
on your own personal
preparation process?
Because obviously
when you have an hour
to speak with all of
us, there's some points
that you want to make.
But at the same time
it's important to be
genuine in your delivery of it.
JOE PLUMERI: That's
a great question.
Because you would have
thought that I prepare.
As you can see,
I'm just talking.
Friends of mine, my wife is
in the back, they're laughing.
Because I've never read
a speech in my life.
I never have.
Because I know the subject.
I know what I want to say.
There's eight
principles in the book,
and I just picked a few that
I thought you'd relate to.
And there's lots of others
that are fun to talk about.
But the preparation is the
intensity of my thinking.
I don't think you
ever stop thinking
about what you're doing.
Lots of times my wife,
Susan, who's here with me
today, she sees me
staring into the abyss,
or staring at a wall.
And she says, what
are you doing?
And she knows I'm
processing in my mind what
I want to say to you guys.
But at the end of
day, it starts here,
but it comes out over here.
So the filter is not a big one.
But if you feel it inside of
you, and it's what you are,
and who you are, then the
integrity shines through.
You can tell whether
I'm a fake or not
by virtue of the way I do it.
So that's the way I process it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JOE PLUMERI: OK?
AUDIENCE: So much
of our schooling
is focused on mathematics,
and that sort of preparation
for the business world.
Do you think it's
important to instill
this relationship-building and
other things in kids early on?
And if so, what is the
appropriate mechanism to do so?
JOE PLUMERI: Thank you, Angela,
that's a very good question.
In my day, they called
that liberal arts,
versus the sciences.
I think it's really important.
I think not only
when you're a child.
And today the sense
of competitiveness,
a sense of striving.
Browning said, your reach
should exceed your grasp,
or what's a heaven for?
And we seem to be breeding
in a society today
a class of children, or
people, where average is good.
I don't think that's good.
I don't think the people who
founded this place sought
to be average.
I think they sought to be
different, and extraordinary.
So I think as kids
are in school,
it's really important to instill
in them a sense of who they
are, allow them to speak the way
they think they should speak,
and what they feel.
When you go to
business schools today,
and I speak at business
schools, there's
very little taught about what it
really takes to run a company.
You got to know
about balance sheets,
and you've got to know about
income statements, and taxes,
and all that kind of stuff.
But I really think what's
important is inspiring people.
And they don't
teach inspiration.
They don't teach motivation.
There's a principle in
the book, show the way
to grandma's house.
And grandma's house is
a metaphor for vision.
That as a child you went
on a trip with your parents
someplace for a long distance.
And eventually,
you got impatient.
And eventually you asked, when
are we going to get there?
Everybody goes through it.
And the parent usually
responds by making up
something that gives you a
vision of how exciting it's
going to be when you
get there, if you'd just
be patient, and settle down.
So in a way, that's a
vision for the future.
Companies should do
that for employees.
People like me should
get up and say, let
me tell you where we're going.
Let me tell you my view
of grandma's house.
This is where we're going.
And it's going to have cake, and
ice cream, and candy, and toys,
and all the things
that are nice.
Or put that in
terms of business.
And the reason
that's important is
so you could endure the trip.
Why do you show up every day?
What's your participation,
or contribution
for what you do to
make the place better,
to get to grandma's house?
And I don't think they teach
that anymore in school.
People just show up.
And you get paid,
hopefully well.
But there's no
sense of really what
do I have to do with what
happens when we get there?
So I am a big proponent.
I've said that business schools,
I've said that at universities.
I think we need to do
more and more to instill
that in our children.
Frankly, I have a granddaughter
who's 13 years old.
And there's a lot
of conversation
that goes on with a
machine, and very little
that goes on with the talking.
And so when you sit down
and you have dinner,
and there's no machine,
it's very difficult
to converse when you're
not used to doing that.
Because you could say a
whole bunch of things.
And somebody says a whole
bunch of things back.
And believe me, I am
not anti-technology.
I just don't think it
should be instead of people.
That's all.
And I think we need to reinstill
that back into our society.
AUDIENCE: Joe, thanks
so much for joining.
Your thoughts, sharing them
has been great to hear.
The optimism, and dynamism
heard from your story,
from what you shared.
So my one question was,
I wonder if there's maybe
a certain point, kind of
a specific time, or place,
or an experience where it
all kind of clicked for you.
And you felt that having
the optimistic path to life
is the way to go, as
opposed to maybe being
a little more realistic,
or being a bit more
pessimistic about things.
Or maybe you were
always like that?
JOE PLUMERI: You're asking me
a very good question, which
makes me think whether there was
any defining moment, which is
what I think you're asking me.
And I don't think I
had a defining moment.
I had a defining father.
This guy thought that
nothing could ever go wrong.
When you're hanging
around role models
like that that are positive,
it's really infectious.
And he just never
believed-- it's in the book,
by the way-- that's why I
can't tell you the whole book,
then you won't read it.
But it's in the book
how positive he was.
But I'll tell you a story, and
it talks about what he did.
And when you read that, you'll
see where it comes from.
Because all my
life, I watched him.
And I watched him
engage with people.
And I watched him be optimistic.
And I watched him just
be such an influence just
by hanging around him.
So there was no
defining moment for me.
But there was just like
a whole bunch of time
that I saw him be positive.
There's a piece in the book
where he used to come and watch
all my ball games.
I played sports.
And one of the stories I
didn't tell in the book,
so I'm going to tell you.
And the guy who helped
me write the book,
Steve Kettmann's in the back.
And I think of all
these things now.
I played football in college.
And you can tell how good I was.
And how good the team was.
We went to play the
University of Virginia.
And they had lost 27 games in
a row, or something like that.
And if we beat them, they
would have set the NCAA record
for consecutive
losses or something.
And so we went to
Charlottesville to play them.
And I had such a terrible day.
I fumbled.
It was just everything wrong.
And they won because of me.
And so I get in the locker
room, and my head was down.
And I saw these shoes
show up in front of me.
And it was my father's shoes.
And he said, why's
your head down?
And I looked up, I said, I
didn't play well-- or something
like that.
And he said, what do mean?
You had a great day.
I said, what are
you talking about?
He says, 40,000 people
now know who you are.
When you have that kind
of influence-- and you'll
see that we owned
the baseball team.
And I remember one
time-- and again, I
didn't put it in the book.
Our team, it was a minor league
affiliate of the Yankees.
I don't know, we
lost 16 to nothing.
And he'd always go
into the clubhouse
after the end of each game.
And he would say, great game.
Great game.
We lost 16 to nothing.
And the coach would
say, how could you
say we had a great game?
He'd say, Oh,
everybody tried hard.
Everybody did the
best they could.
That was the kind of guy he was.
So when you hang around
that all your life,
which goes to another message.
Hang around people that
are positive influences.
Stay close to people who
can be helpful to you,
and not drag you
down, but pick you up.
You got those choices.
And I think that's
where I got mine from.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds like it's
almost kind of this tendency
to resilience, which
maybe you cultivated just
from seeing your dad,
and going through that.
JOE PLUMERI: Yeah,
and again, I think
you are a product of something.
And I was a product
of what I saw.
And I was lucky
enough-- I could have
seen something
else that would've
been not as productive.
But I had the privilege,
and the good fortune
of seeing somebody that
had a positive influence.
The guy just wouldn't give up.
He just kept bouncing
back up again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOE PLUMERI: Yeah, and so that's
why I think it's important.
And there are subtle messages.
And you'll see, cut a path is
the principle in the book which
talks about my father
and my grandfather,
and the legacy in my family
of always cutting a path.
There's choices
you have in life.
I gave you one of them, pain
of discipline, pain of regret.
The other one is, cut a
path and leave a trail.
Or let somebody else cut the
path, and you follow them.
In business, first
to the market wins.
In life, I think you
just go cut a path,
and then wait for everybody
else to want to follow you.
They're not the ones
that are the winners.
This place is a great
example of that.
So he was always a person that
cut a path, and left a trail.
And I've always
been the same way.
And in business, it's called
be the first to the market,
and you win.
Same thing with your customers.
If you have a customer, you
don't sell them, you help them.
It's subtle things
like that make
you feel and want people to do
better, and they're positive.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is, you mentioned
that you kind of regret
not having spent more time
with your son before he passed.
After he did pass
away, did you see
a change in kind of
the amount of time
you spent with either
family, or time you took off,
or in terms of how
much you worked
as a learning out of that?
And then what kind of things you
recommend for people these days
to kind of--
JOE PLUMERI: The answer is yes.
I have.
And frankly, when I was
on a plane last night,
I asked my wife.
He had a daughter, who's now 13,
who my ex-wife and I adopted.
And her name is Elizabeth.
And so I'm the father,
and the grandfather.
And I worry that I don't
spend enough time with her.
I mentioned that to
my wife last night.
I said, I gotta spend
more time with Elizabeth.
I don't know that I could
even ask that question
before the tragedy.
I wouldn't have even asked it.
I think I'm pretty close
to my other children,
but I get paranoid that I'm not.
Because when you go through
something like that,
you're constantly
questioning whether you're
doing the right thing or not.
Whether you said the
right thing or not.
But I think it's healthy.
I think it's healthy that
I constantly question,
am I doing this right?
Or I constantly question,
am I spending enough time
like I should?
All because of the
experience that I had.
And as long as I keep
questioning myself,
I think that's healthy.
So my recommendation
would be, don't
go through what I went through.
But keep questioning everything
that you do personally
with your friends,
or with your family.
And question whether
or not the relationship
is as tight as it should be, and
as heartfelt as it should be.
AUDIENCE: Just really
quickly, on the subject
of questioning yourself.
How do you balance questioning
yourself versus confidence?
JOE PLUMERI: Questioning
I go back to swagger.
You know the word swagger?
Everybody always says,
that guy's got swagger.
That lady has swagger, right?
And there's something
cool about swagger.
And so I always try to
think about what swagger
would be if you defined it.
And this is what swagger is.
You ready?
North of confident,
and south of arrogant.
You've got it?
You want to be around
confident people,
but you don't want to be around
people that are arrogant.
Right?
You want to be around,
this is a confident person
who has a sense of class, style,
and has respect for people.
And so you want to stay south
of arrogant, north of confident,
and that land right there
is where you want to be.
And that's swagger.
And always keep
asking yourself, did I
do something that was confident?
Or did I go above the
line of arrogance?
OK?
Got it?
North of confident,
south of arrogant
is the swagger you want
to have every day, when
you think anything's possible.
OK?
I want to really thank
you guys for coming today.
It's really been a lot of fun.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate you giving me the
opportunity to talk to you,
and spend the time with you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]